В школі я вчилась не дуже погано,
але завжди страждала дисципліна,
завжди мала проблеми з вчителями.
Моїх батьків дуже часто викликали.
Вітаю на уроці географії з
Галиною Іванівною Карпюк.
Сьогодні у нас на уроці крім мене,
учителя, є гостя - Даша Астаф’єва.
- Дякую.
- Вітаю вас.
- Вітаю.
Тема нашого уроку, я
думаю, ви вже здогадалися:
“Гірські ландшафти Українських Карпат”.
Ми з вами пройшли всі типи
рівнинних ландшафтів України,
познайомились з зоною мішаних лісів,
широколистих лісів, лісостепу, степу
і ось нарешті ландшафти
гірських країн - Українські Карпати.
Де знаходиться ця територія? Передусім на
карті ми бачимо ось цей трикутник,
стиснутий між державним
кордоном України і умовною лінією,
яка проходить через Чернівці,
Івано-Франківськ і частиною Львівської
області. Це велика територія, протяжністю
понад 280 км і шириною близько 100 км.
І це є окрема фізико-географічна “країна”.
Подивіться на оцю невеличку карто-схемку.
Рельєфно відображено
всю гірську країну Карпат.
Це є продовженням Альп, тобто є складовою
Альпійсько-Гімалайського поясу, і у межах
України знаходиться невеличка частинка,
яку ми називаємо Українськими Карпатами.
В Карпатах бували не всі.
Ті, хто їде туди вперше,
передусім з нетерпінням виглядаючи
у вікно автобуса, автомобіля, поїзда,
чекає коли ж вони почнуться, такі,
здається, знайомі з дитинства обриси гір.
Особливо, ті хто живе на
рівнинах, і ті хто їде туди вперше
спочатку перетинають
Передкарпатську височину.
Наче і “карпати” в назві Передкарпаття,
але практично рівнинний рельєф.
Дорога біжить вверх-вниз, висоти 300-400
метрів, а Карпат все і нема і нема.
Хто їде з Києва, а тим
паче зі сходу країни,
попадає туди, як правило, під вечір.
Лише така маленька картинка
показує вам оті такі очікувані обриси
- першу лінію Карпат.
І далі починаються гори.
Візьмемо карту. Сьогодні впродовж
уроку найкраще працювати з картою.
Чому? Вона допомагає нам
зорієнтуватись в тому, де ми,
в якій частині знаходимося, що
ми бачимо і як потім це знайти.
Я не обіцяю вам пляшку зі 100 доларами,
але враження ви точно отримаєте.
Так от, подивітся, в’їжджаючи
чи з Франківська, чи з Львівщини,
чи з Чернівців, перетнувши
Передкарпатську височину,
ви потрапляєте в гірські Карпати.
Ось вони, ці гірські Карпати.
Одне пасмо, друге, третє.
Ці пасма ніби розділені окремими
розломами, глибокими долинами,
на окремі масиви.
Їх можна умовно об'єднати.
Перше пасмо складається
із кількох окремих масивів,
називаємо їх Баскиди, Горгани і
Покутсько-Буковинські Карпати.
Що це за Карпати і які вони?
Мандрівнику передусім
відривається картина гірського хребта.
Він не суцільний, він розділений
на окремі невисокі гори,
і ми бачимо, м'які обриси
- вкриті лісом Баскиди.
Це середньо висотні гори, де найвища гора
- Магура - піднімається лише на 1362 м.
Але якщо стати на вершині Магури,
там є таке місце, де немає лісу.
І якщо глянути на південний
схід, то там здається гори вищі.
Вони дійсно вищі, тільки
вони просто далеко.
В Карпатах завжди все здається близько,
тому що повітря таке чисте,
що, здається, ось кілька кроків,
ну кількасот метрів, ну може
пару кілометрів, і я там буду.
Насправді дуже оманлива така картинка.
Дивіться, Баскиди, і ось ми
далі бачимо вищі гори - Горгани.
1836 метрів - це ще середня висота
- найвища вершина Сивуля Велика,
але вони вже більш схожі на ті
Карпати, які ми малюємо собі в уяві.
А потім Покутсько-Буковинські Карпати.
Ось ці Горгани ближче. Подивіться,
немає лісу, він лишився десь внизу.
Вершина Сивуля Велика вже вкрита
тільки окремими острівцями рослинності,
а то майже голий камінь. Ось він такий
вигляд має, вищий масив.
Але якщо ми його здолаємо,
там знов будуть невисокі гори,
вкриті лісом, схожі на Баскиди.
Якщо ми перетнули перше пасмо,
здається, далі будуть вищі гори,
адже ми йдемо вглиб Карпат.
Насправді не так. Вздовж кордону,
скажімо так, умовної межі між
Закарпатською областю,
Івано-Франківською і Львівською
лежить хребет дещо нижчий.
Це вододільний хребет.
Вододільний хребет має
висоти від 900 до 1000 метрів.
Місцями трошки вище, але він
впирається в найвищий масив.
Який вигляд вододільного хребта?
Ви його побачите з віконця поїзда,
автобуса, можливо, автомобіля.
Долаючи Ужоцький перевал, ви
ніби губитесь - в'їхали в Карпати,
а насправді вони десь зникають.
Широкі полонини, села, дорога веде...
Якщо ви їдете через Воловецький перевал
(це може бути тільки поїздом,
там занадто складна дорога,
щоб її автомобілем долати),
то обов'язково проїдетесь
новеньким Бескидським
тунелем - 1700 метрів.
- Даша, ви їхали колись в тунелі?
- Ні, ніколи.
- А там, тільки в'їхали, і треба
одразу припинити дихати...
- і загадати бажання!
- Правильно!
А от Яблуницький
перевал, він ніби справжній.
От стоїш на перевалі і навколо гори і
смереки. Здається, що це точно Карпати.
Подолавши оці перевали, ми
в'їжджаємо далі вглиб Карпат.
Але пам'ятаємо
- ми перетнули вододільний хребет,
він невисокий, але він ділить
умовно річки: ті які стікають,
і несуть свої води в Дністер, і ті річки,
які несуть свої води в Дунай, в Тису.
Таким чином, спускаючись далі на південний
схід, ми потрапляємо у найвищі гори.
От тут знаходяться двотисячники.
Подивіться на оці картинки.
Петрос, Говерла - 2061 метр, за
деякими джерелами - 2062 метри.
Ось вона у всій красі.
З однієї сторони і з іншої.
Вона завжди має чіткий обрис в ясну
погоду, а якщо похмуро - вона виділяється,
інколи ховаючись за хмари,
тільки своєю широкою основою.
Ось гляньте, яка вона - ніби
Каспер. Вкрита снігом взимку,
вона нагадує казкового привида.
Вона завжди вкрита снігом взимку.
Ось оцей масив - Чорногора, він
найвищий. Ще трошки південніше
і на південний захід знаходиться
найдавніший - Мармароський,
і там також гори добираються
до двох тисяч метрів.
А ось далі подивіться, ще один
хребет він називається Полонинський.
І вже в своїй уяві малюєте полонини.
Тобто, м'які обриси хребта,
а вершинивкриті травами.
І закінчується Карпати
вулканічним хребтом.
Якщо зробити панорамний
знімок, десь здалеку-здалеку,
можна побачити ось такий м'який
обрис невеликих гірських форм рельєфу.
Зблизька дійсно видно, що це гори
вкриті лісом, містями полонини і поля.
Карпати закінчились.
Підсумуємо.
Середньо висотні гори, які простягаються з
північного-заходу на південний-схід
параллельными пасмами.
В межах хребта є глибокі
тектонічні розломи новітнього часу,
поглиблені річками, тому
Карпати можна поділити, умовно,
кожне пасмо на кілька масивів,
які мають дуже цікаві назви.
Спробуємо розібратись де взялись Карпати.
На тектонічній карті бачимо межу
Східноєвропейської платформи.
Ось вона, позначена рожевою лінією. За
цією лінією ідуть безпосередньо Карпати.
Ми бачимо, що це окрема країна. Чому?
Тому, що фізико-географічна
країна - це тойландшафтний комплекс,
який відділяється в межах
єдиної тектонічної структури.
Якщо Східноєвропейська платформа
у нас іде на захід і північний захід,
то на південний схід у нас іде
карпатська фізико-географічна країна.
Читаємо в умовних знаках:
написано "складчаста споруда".
Як утворилась така складчаста споруда?
Крейдовий період. Мезозой. Закарпаття
хлюпоче неглибоким морем.
Кайнозойська ера. Палеоген.
Подивіться на цю маленьку чорну плямку.
Рахівський масив. Там
уже гори, решта території.
Он Закарпаття тільки починається
- підняття суходолу над водоймою.
І безпосередньо в неогені уже ми бачимо
- карпатська країна у
вигляді гірської споруди.
Отже, гори молоді, так як і Альпи.
Просто не було таких інтенсивних рухів,
щоб вони піднялися до
такої висоти, як Альпи.
Тому ми можемо одразу сказати, якщо
було море, відкладались садові породи;
коли почалося горотворення,
осадові породи зім'ялися в складочки.
Давайте повернемося на
попередній слайд. Карпатський фліш.
Подивіться як гарно видно,
як складочки зминаються.
Ось ці породи відкладенні
в Мезозойському морі.
Швидше за все, це вапнякові породи.
А ось гляньте, який красивий фліш
на березі річки. Видно гірські породи
- в середині старіші, зверху
молодші, і ще молодші.
Коли йшло стикання літосферних плит,
ці породи зім'яли складочки, вигнулись,
а потім по розлому річечка
поглибила, знесла все
і відкрила нам геологічну
історію цього краю.
Таким чином ми бачимо,
що в складки зім'яті породи
(читаємо геологічну карту ми вже
який рік підряд ми її повторюємо),
що ось це Крейдовий період -
зелений, Кайнозойська ера - ось.
Ідуть породи палеогену, неогену.
Таким чином, ми з вами бачимо кольори
кількох ер: кайнозою і мезозою.
А найстаріші породи ось в
цьому місці, в Рахівському масиві.
Там найраніше почали утворюватись гори.
Отже, це молоді гори і не надійтесь
на те, шо там буде велика кількість
корисних копалин, особливо,
магматично-метаморфічного походження.
Дарма, можливо, у вулканічному хребті...
Можливо, ось тут, в Мармароському масиві,
але в основному Карпати
складені осадовими породами.
Що це за породи? Пісковики,
глини, глинисті сланці.
Оця вся територія - це передусім сировина
для виробнитства будівельних матеріалів.
Місцями є інші види ресурсів - ось тут
можуть бути руди у вулканіних породах.
Але дорогоцінне
каміння, великі рудні жили
- вони або глибоко,
або невеликі за обсягом,
і розробляти їх недоцільно не тільки
тому, що це великі витрати грошей,
а ще, можливо, й тому, що
передусім треба зберегти Карпати
як цілісний природний комплекс.
А тепер клімат Карпат.
От коли ви влітку їдете в Карпати,
про що ви передусім маєте
подумати, глянувши на прогноз погоди?
Що треба взяти з собою?
- Теплий одяг, щось від дощу.
- Правильно. Ось зо таке знання.
Даша точно була в Карпатах.
Тому що коли ми глянемо на карту
(так, це область помірного клімату),
але ми знаємо, що з
висотою температура падає
- на 1000 метрів піднялись і
на 6 градусів холодніше.
На 100 метрів піднялись
- на 10 днів пізніше літо прийде
і на 5 днів осінь настане.
Тому рухаючись Карпатами, у
нас завжди є запас теплого одягу,
бажано ще й вологонепроникного.
Потрібна парасоля. Подивіться, скільки
опадів випадає у високогір’ях Карпат!
Особливо на Чорногорі.
Якщо тут ми маємо 600-800 міліметрів,
то тут понад 1000 - 1500 міліметрів.
А це означає, що можуть бути
і затяжні дощі, і злива, і гроза.
Інколи в Карпатах дуже складно
навіть від грози заховатися.
Взимку тут випадає багато снігу.
Напровесні бувають снігові лавини, коли
сніг стрімко тане, змішуються тала вода із
камінням, глиною, піском, з тими садовими
пухкими породами і летять потоки селлю.
Споглядаючи Карпати, ми маємо знати,
що клімат помірний - там всього в міру:
і гарного і небезпечного. Про це треба
пам'ятати і наперед дивитися прогноз,
особливо коли ви вирушаєте в Карпати.
А ще питати в місцевих жителів, вони добре
знають ту місцину і все вам розкажуть.
Найбільше дощів буває влітку. А ми
найчастіше мандруємо в Карпатах влітку,
тому завжди до такої поїздки готуємося.
Якщо багато опадів, багато води, вона
стікає по схилах - у Карпатах багато річок.
Подивіться. Оця частиночка
- це басейн Дністра.
А ось Закарпаття - на заході,
південному заході від вододільного хребта.
А Чорногора і Буковинські Карпати -
це вже басейн Тиси і Пруда.
А це притоки Дунаю, тому карпатський
регіон - це два річкові великі басейни.
Разом з тим, самі річечки на перший погляд
невеликі.
Вони мають не дуже широке русло.
Здається, вони не глибокі,
он видно і каміння.
Але згадаймо скільки
влітку там може бути опадів.
Якщо пройшов сильний дощ
десь в верховітті Карпат, то на ранок,
якщо ви не подумали і
поставили тут палатку,
вода з русла з річища
може піднятись на заплаву.
Це небезпечно, тому ці річки
здаються такими веселими і грайливими
тільки в сонячну погоду.
А ось після танення снігів вода
виходить з берегів і затоплює заплаву.
Річки стають каламутними,
бурхливими, несуть каміння, бруд і сміття,
яке ви лишили там, якщо не подумавши,
залишили десь пакетик із сміттям.
Воно обов'язково потрапить в річку.
А потім, можливо, й до моря дійде.
І такі “привіти” залишати
в Карпатах не потрібно!
Карпатські річки це, передусім,
гідроенергетичний потенціал.
Так, така вода тече швидко,
це великий енергетичний ресурс,
і відповідно можна поставити греблю.
Але ця гребля підніме рівень води.
Підніме рівень води настільки, що буде її
вигідно будувати і отримуватиелектрику.
Але тоді всієї цієї краси не буде.
Не тільки порогів і
водоспадів, не буде й заплави,
не буде можливості в риб рухатись річкою.
Не буде можливості у нас з
вами сплавлятись по цих річках.
Тому будівнитство таких
невеликих гідроелектростанцій
може знищити всю цю красу
і цей рекреаційний потенціал.
Альтернативною вартістю буде електрика.
І тут треба враховувати не
тільки економічну доцільність,
а й екологічну, рекреаційну
і просто духовну.
А ще в Карпатах багато озер.
Найвище озеро - Синевир.
Але воно і велике по
площі - має 24 м глибини.
Ось за цим острівцем воно потайки
стежить за небом над Карпатами.
І також змінюється так, як і небо
- буває бакитим, буває зеленавим,
буває темним, сірим, непривітним.
Але воно чисте і гарне.
Буде у вас можливість,
обов'язково відвідайте Синевир.
А це маленькі льодовикові озера,
вони також невеличкі за площею
і знаходяться на великих висотах.
Їх залишив льодовик.
Дивіться, 1800, понад 1500 метрів.
Марічейка, Бребенескул, Несамовите
- це також унікальні об'єкти
для туристів, які вирушають в Карпати.
Природні зони в Карпатах
змінюються з висотою.
Це закон висотної поясності.
За цим законом ми маємо пам'ятати, що біля
підніжжя гір будуть ті природні комплекси,
в яких розміщені гори.
Тому повертаємось до відомої
вже вам карти природних зон.
Ось карпатська гірська країна, а
навколо зона мішаних і широколистих лісів.
Тобто біля підніжжя Карпатських гір
мають бути ліси.
Дивимося приблизну схему
висотної поясності в Карпатах.
Таких ідеальних ліній на висоті
600 метрів, 900 метрів не буває.
Як правило, десь на висоті
500 метрів, десь 600 метрів,
а десь і 700 метрів
завершується передгір'я.
В передгір'ї відомий вже вам
бук, граб, дуб, вільха, осика.
Піднімаємось на висоту 600 метрів, і
температура вже на 3 градуси нижче.
І далі - царство букових
лісів з домішкою смереки.
Ґрунти з дерново-підзолистих
змінюються бурими гірськими,
а на висоті 800-900 метрів
з’являється ялина і смерека.
Ялиново-смерекові ліси піднімаються
до висоти десь 1500 метрів.
Якщо ви знаходитесь на
висоті 1500-1600 метрів,
то ви так дізнаєтесь яка це висота,
тому що зникають дерева
і вище з’являються субальпійські
високогірні луки і криволісся.
А ще вище - альпійські луки.
Пройдемося цими місцями.
Ми входили в Карпати з заходу,
там були грабово-буково-дубові ліси.
Закарпаття - це також будуть
широколисті ліси, але ось цей слайд
навертає вас в одну місцину, де
ви зробите собі прекрасні фото.
Основне - не зашкодити.
Це долина нарцисів.
В травні місяці вона вся
вкривається білим цвітом.
А ось широколистий ліс. В карпатах
він стрункий, високий, колонавий.
Подивіться, він вабить, і в
ньому можна йти, гублячись.
В карпатах інколи не завжди
впізнаєш де північ, а де південь,
тому що з однієї сторони може бути схил,
а з другої спуск в долину,
і за мохом в деревині не надійтесь
так легко це визначити.
А ось такий вигляд має смерековий ліс.
Подивіться на ці місцини,
смерековий ліс хворіє.
Сьогодні багато є ідей як
з'явилася смерека в Карпатах.
І дуже багато лісників намагаються
докласти зусиль, щоб зберегти цей ліс
не тільки від шкідників, а й від
хвороб. Мабуть, є тому якась причина.
Можливо, глобальне потепління,
можливо, щось в атмосфері не так,
можливо, не так доглядаємо за
лісом, але це вже проблема наукова,
а нам основне не залишити в
цьому лісі після себе такий слід,
який би міг спричинити пожежу. І на
деревах слід залишати теж не треба.
А вище дерева обламуються сильними вітрами
або набувають такої викривленої форми.
Ось такий вигляд має карпатське
криволісся, а ще вище - луки.
Якщо ви дивитеся фільми, зняті у Карпатах,
ви ніби уявно сідаєте в цю високу траву.
Це все навіть назвати не можна.
Десятки видів трав навколо вас!
Хочеться їх зірвати, скласти, посушити…
А як не виходить, то купіть великий пакет
карпатського чаю, розкладіть на столі,
і знайдете там і злаки, і квітучі трави.
Субальпійські луки злаково різнотравні і
високі, тут косять сіно, на цих полонинах,
а вище луки стають нижчими, видів менше,
і поступово це різнотрав’я залишається
тільки окремими острівцями на схилах гір.
Ось отак ви бачите
криволісся, ось уже лишайникові,
трав'янисті ділянки з різних
схилів, залежно від того,
схил повернутий на південь чи на північ.
Але ж гарно скрізь!
Взимку Карпати ось такі.
Дивлячись на цей малюночок,
ви можете одразу сказати, що
тут немає висоти 1600 метрів.
Тобто якщо на вершині росте ліс, то
немає, а ось там, мабуть, точно є.
А на панорамі здається, що та гора нижча
за цю. Це ще один оптичний обман Карпат.
А ось оце спуски. Гірськолижні
траси - це той вид відпочинку,
який приваблює людей в Карпати.
А ще Карпати - це окреме царство тварин.
Блукати просто так диким
лісом навіть небезпечно!
Ви можете зустріти не тільки
вовка, а й рись, лісового кота.
Там ще місцями
блукають дикі бурі ведмеді.
Там є багато інших тварин:
і співучих птахів, і плазунів,
і червонокнижних тварин.
Рухаючись в Карпати, відкрийте
довідник, прочитайте, познайомтесь з ними
і намагайтесь їх зайве не тривожити.
І якщо написано в заказнику
чи національному парку
“час гніздування птахів”,
вимкніть музику, рухайтесь тихенько,
бо у цих пташок
важлива сімейна справа
і не треба їм заважати.
А тепер гляньте на ось
цю карту охорони природи.
Подивіться скільки тут розміщено кульок.
Кожна з цих кульок - заповідники.
Фіолетові - біосферені.
Це Карпатський біосферний заповідник.
А рожеві - це природні заповідники, а ще
є національні парки, заказники, урочища.
В Карпатах більше, ніж в
будь-якому іншому регіоні,
природоохоронних територій і це,
мабуть, найбільше нас має радувати.
Тому, вирушаючи в Карпати, ви
передусім повинні приготувати собі карту,
подивитись прогноз погоди, познайомитися
з традиціями місцевих жителів,
вивчити особливості і
повадки диких тварин,
визначити, які рослини червонокнижні.
Мабуть, на те і є таке поняття як
освіченість, щоб робити все розумно.
Я бажаю вам гарних подорожей, я бажаю вам
гарних фотографій. Не треба колекціонувати
часточки природи - колекціонуйте враження,
це найцінніше, що ви привезете з Карпат.
Урок у нас закінчується,
і я хотіла б запитати у нашої учениці,
чи вона була в Карпатах.
- Так, я була декілька разів і мені дуже
сподобалося,
тому що карпатський колорит не
схожий ні на яку іншу територію України.
Ми ходили в тур по гриби, назбирали більше
ніж 14 кілограмів та привезли додому!
Також я була декілька разів
на лижних курортах.
Мені також дуже сподобалось.
Зокрема, сподобались закарпатські страви.
Вони такі неповторні!
- А наприклад?
- Наприклад, вареники з диким м’ясом,
банош, грибна юшка.
Це дуже смачно і ніде так не готують!
Це моя думка.
- Добре. Наш урок добігає кінця.
Я бажаю вам успіхів у
вашому пізнанні Карпат,
а також бажаю обов’язково здійснити мрію
- прогулятись карпатськими полонинами,
проїхатись дорогами, посмакувати
грибну юшку і банош,
відвідати карпатські курорти,
полікуватись мінеральними водами
і ще багато-багато чого, що ви зможете
зробити в Карпатах. Дякую. за увагу.
- І вам дякую.
Влітку.
Смерека.